دخلت الدبابات الروسية إلى قرية
ليبيفكا في أواخر فبراير وهي
الآن مسؤولة هنا
عن
الحياة والموت بعد
ستة أسابيع عادت الآن السيطرة
على القرية ، بدأت السلطات الأوكرانية في
عد القتلى
[موسيقى]
لا أستطيع النظر تقول إن إحدى الأمهات
كانت بعد ذلك فقط  كانت الدبابات قد
سحبت أن المدعين الأوكرانيين
تمكنوا من البدء في تجميع
ما حدث ،
وهم يشتبهون الآن في ارتكاب هؤلاء الرجال لجرائم
تنتهك قواعد
وأعراف الحرب في هذا الشارع.
عشرة
أيام من إلحاق الأذى الجسدي
وتنفيذ عمليات إعدام وهمية
أردنا أن نرى بأنفسنا
بعض هذه الجرائم المزعومة قد تكون
قد ارتكبت من
الباب إلى الباب بصور
للجنود الذين التقينا بهم ، ومن يتعرف
على أحدهم هل
هو
مقفل يقودنا إلى الأسفل  إلى قبو حيث
يقول إن الجنود الروس حاولوا قتل
مجموعة من الرجال والنساء الذين كانوا يختبئون
، واستخدموا القنابل اليدوية والبنادق.
لكن المدنيين تمكنوا من البقاء على قيد الحياة من خلال
التوجه أكثر إلى الظلام ،
هذا مشهد واحد فقط من
الجرائم المزعومة لرجال اللواء 64
حيث تتناثر فيها السجائر وأغلفة الرصاص.
يتعرف القائد فاسيل
ليبينكو عليه على
الفور ويدعونا إلى ما تبقى من منزله
الذي اختبأه هو وعائلته في الغابة كما
يقول بينما دمر منزله بواسطة
المدفعية الروسية التي قتلت جاره
عندما حاول العودة ، يقول إن
القائد بدا  فاجأه
قال ما الذي تفعله هنا كان
يجب أن تحرق حياً
ميشيلا ما زالت لا تعرف لماذا
قرر أن يتركه يعيش
اغتصاب الناس الذين يعذبون الناس على
ماذا
لأنهم أرادوا
تخويف المدنيين يخيفون مواطنينا من البلدات
والمدن والقرى
بعد الانسحاب منها.  منطقة الجزار
التي روجت موسكو لرجال اللواء ،
نفى الكرملين أي تورط
في القتل الجماعي
، تم إنشاء اللواء 64  بعد
الحرب الجورجية وفقًا للمخابرات الأوكرانية
، لوحظ أن جنود هذا اللواء قد اشتُهروا بعمليات السطو والاغتصاب التي ارتكبوها ،
ولكن بدلاً من فرض النظام على
اللواء ، قامت القيادة الروسية
بتسليحها بأسلحة حديثة وأرسلها
إلى أوكرانيا
دون أن يتوصل إلى ما هو بالضبط.
ربما يكون الجنود الروس الذين احتلوا هذه المنطقة
شمال كييف
مسؤولين عن السؤال الكبير
للمدعين العامين الأوكرانيين الآن
وهو أين هم
ميليسا بيل سي إن كييف.